[Music]
yeah well you're preaching to the choir
here and and I completely agree that's
why I jumped ship from my you know job
at the studio table your door because
you were personally motivated to stop
living that way yeah but can you talk
about the dark side because I think
there is a dark side
you know Mo Money mo problems right yeah
you know how does one and I think maybe
people watching will want to know sort
of like how do we navigate those choppy
waters because it's not just it's not so
simple right when success starts to come
no you start being less kind to the
hospitality people or the you know the
person who brings you your food you know
right you used to be the bottle washer
or the the gums paper and now you're the
owner so like how do you navigate around
staying grounded staying a human being
and not-being
becoming such a rich jerk that's a great
question perhaps your best one of the
day in some ways because it's easy to
slide into that Ric Rich Jerk mode the
answer is you have to have respect for
people for their own talents for who
they are what they do the guy that
delivers your breakfast in the morning
you should respect him like any but like
the like the like Warren Buffett it's
this it doesn't matter he's a person
he's trying to do his job she's trying
to do her job they deserve your respect
if you if you can't give them respect
and you treat them without respect you
have become an [ __ ] and you deserve
in my view the Karma that comes with
that I believe there is karma and I
think if you're a real [ __ ] you're
gonna pay the price one day that's why I
have to get back that's why have to
treat people with respect and you have
to remember that that there's always the
way weighing in during your life and
karma is how that gets settled the other
big area that it manifests itself as a
huge problem is in children if you D
risk your children's lives you are
giving them a disease so you're talking
about kind of how Bill Gates and Warren
Buffett's deal with their children they
say you get nothing you're entitled to
nothing
what is your outlook on you know the the
success you've had dear children feel
entitled to it do they know they're
getting something nothing or all of it
well here's here's the lesson I learned
when I was graduating from college my
mother said to me I'm coming into
graduation I've got the great news I'm
coming I want to see this happen but no
more checks that's it I've paid from
birth the last day of college you're on
your own and I said mom I don't have a
job I have no money you know and she
said the dead bird under the nest never
learns how to fly and I said mom that's
great poem but I need some cash she said
no and it was a very traumatic couple of
years after that trying to find my way
and I had no money and I was really in a
bad bad shape but the whole point was
she felt that the journey of you know
paying for right to the end of college
was on her back and that she had done
that and now it was my turn to launch
and go on that was such a powerful
experience for me that I've now mandated
that into my family trust which is a
generational skipping trust provides
from children born into future
generations
even out of wedlock I don't care it's a
full freight pay from birth to last day
of college and then they get this
nothing now when I put the structure in
place on my first liquidity event was
around the sale of the Learning Company
I walked across the river to Cambridge
met with the lawyers and said I want to
structure this thing this way and they
said you sure I said I've talked my wife
about it we had you know when we were
married we had no money and I went back
and explained the structure and my kids
after I'd locked and loaded it they were
four and six decades late well you know
I guess 12 years later my son was doing
very poorly in high school I think it
around grade 10
he was not gonna get to college and and
he came to me and said dad walk me
through the trust deal again I said sure
Trevor it's very easy here's how it
works if mom and I go what go out to a
movie tonight we get run over
it's you're gonna be okay because you're
gonna be taken care of right to finish
high school because it doesn't look like
you have to worry about college and then
he said well what happens after that I
said you're on your own
you get nothing he said I get nothing
I said yeah the dead bird under the nest
never learns how to fly and he said that
sucks but I said why don't you take
advantage of the runway you've got your
grade 10 it's full frame now he's in
third year electrical engineering maybe
that was a night that it hit him where
the fear of the unknown you know could
be avoided by finding a path and he's
used it and he's spent a lot of money
getting his education but I'm sure when
he graduates he'll have a job and I told
him if you want to start a company don't
come to me I'm expensive I want a
royalty but then raise some dough and
come to me later for second round
financing or something
because I really think you know that's
the whole point of helping you know
having everything taken care of from
birth less they've college is a good
deal for anybody yeah but I'm not giving
them a dearest life and I think that's
another you know issue you have to deal
with and so that money will sit in trust
and just roll on long after I'm going to
do whatever it does I want Carol be dead
[Music]